the following five architects have a net  worth that will make your eyes water  starting in at number five bjark ingles  has a net worth of 17 million dollars  number four is renzo piano only slightly  above the arc angles with 20 million  dollars number three is the late and  great zaha hadid with 95 million dollars  of net worth to her current name and  family estate the legendary frank gehry  comes in at number two with a net worth  of a hundred million dollars coming in  at number one is norman foster norman  foster with his firm norman foster and  partners subsequently destroys everybody  on this list with an estimated net worth  of 240  million dollars